wenn ich an bin habe ich die möglichkeit
vor allem in deutschland mehr zu
arbeiten mehr zu investieren und
vermögend auch so machen aber ich hab's
doch geschafft ich bin schwarz und ich
bin schwerbehindert und ich hatte scheiß
einstiegschancen 13 fragen hier kommt
die erste ist erben gerecht wenn ihr
sagt ja dann bitte auf dem grünfeld
positionieren und wenn ihr sagt nee das
ganze system muss dringend reformiert
werden dann bitte auf dem gelben feld
positionieren und bitte so vielen dank
jetzt wissen wir wo ihr es steht aber wo
steht ihr in deutschland werden pro jahr
rund 200 bis 400 milliarden euro vererbt
oder verschenkt und das weitgehend
steuerfrei also eine gewaltige summe
der größte anteil dieses erbschafts
kuchens geht an diejenigen die ohnehin
schon das meiste vermögen haben ganz
wertfrei gesagt verstärkt also erben die
finanzielle ungleichheit ja gut sagen
die einen
meine familie hat ja auch viel
lebenszeit und viel energie in den
aufbau des vermögens gesteckt vielleicht
sogar ein unternehmen gegründet
arbeitsplätze geschaffen und obendrein
noch gespart
und jetzt kommt ihr und wollte das den
nachkommen wegnehmen gibt ungerecht das
denn
moment sagen die anderen erbschaft das
ist ja erstmal leistungslose vermögen
das heißt du hast dafür erst mal gar
nichts getan
nur weil du zufälligerweise das große
los in der eizellen lotterie gezogen
hast bist du jetzt reich und zb die
tochter einer krankenpflegerin ist haben
pore glückssache
wie ungerecht ist das denn irgendwo auf
den zwei seiten dieser konfliktlinie
haben sich natürlich auch meinen
heutigen gäste positioniert die
spannende frage ist wie kriegen wir sie
wieder zusammen denn bei 310 fragen geht
es ja um kompromisse
also es wird spannend zu sehen sein ob
uns ein kompromiss gelingt oder sogar
einen lösungsvorschlag wo würdet ihr
euch positionieren auf grün oder
erbschaft system ist so insgesamt schon
ganz okay bruder auf gelb nein es muss
dringend reformiert werden
schreiben sie mir gerne in die
kommentare die spielregeln sind ja ganz
einfach wenn ihr im laufe der diskussion
glaubt die gegenseite hat da einen punkt
dann würde ich euch bitten kommt einen
schritt auf sie zu und wenn er sagt das
was du jetzt erzählt ist totaler quatsch
dann könnt ihr einen schritt zurückgehen
also ich ein bisschen entfernt das ziel
mein ziel ist es am ende möglichst viele
von euch hier in diese mitte zu bringen
auf das sogenannte kompromiss fällt auf
in der hoffnung dass wir irgendeine
lösung finden in dieser diskussion
soweit alles klar
gut hier kommt frage nummer zwei und die
geht an marlene deiner familie gehörte
zu einem der reichsten in österreich das
heißt wirst mal sehr sehr viel geld
erben
die meisten leute würden sich darüber
sehr freuen du ärgerst dich darüber
warum da kommen darauf dass man
betrachtet also grundsätzlich über ein
geschenk kann man sich schon freuen aber
wenn man sieht dass da eine strukturelle
ungleichheit fährt wird da muss man sich
schon fragen ok auf wessen kosten geht
denn hier mein reichtum
wer hat denn er arbeitet wer sie davon
nichts und warum nicht dass die
verteilungsfrage nicht demokratisch
öffentlich transparent und gerecht
geregelt wird
ist eigentlich ein politischer skandal
ich möchte mein erbe um verteilen lassen
von einem demokratischen staat damit das
was alle was angeht nämlich wie geld
verwaltet wird in demokratischen händen
passiert und nicht von einzelpersonen
entschieden wird ich habe nicht für
dieses erbe getan und wenn man sich
diese fragen mal konsequent zuende aus
kaarst bad inklusive der frage wie viel
es genug was das gute leben für alle
nach dem demokratischen prinzip was alle
etwas angeht sollten alle entscheiden
dann überlegt man schon macht das
wirklich sind wenn eine person so viel
geld bekommt zumal das er mit macht
einhergeht mit lebenschancen ich kann
mir auch bequem jetzt die medien
einkaufen gehen die politik einkaufen
gehen die wirtschaft einkaufen gehen ist
jetzt auch nicht unüblich und ich denke
das hat dann mit demokratie nichts mehr
zu tun wir haben jetzt zwei frauen die
beide erben oder erben werden
anastasia du wirst ja auch dazu aber du
sagst eine höhere erbschaftssteuer nicht
das finde ich ungerecht warum also meine
mutter ist alleinerziehend
sie hat sich das alles selber aufgebaut
ich habe eben dieses argument meine mama
hatte keine zeit für mich meine mutter
hat gearbeitet war bei veranstaltungen
hat er gemacht während ich zu hause war
aber im grossen ganzen das was ich
gegründet hat nämlich mein startup
elemente was der gesellschaft als etwas
zurückgibt kam daher dass sie dieses
polster meiner mutter hatte was sie mit
verzicht aufgebaut hat mein leben
verändert sich durch das wissen dass ich
irgendwann erben werde das ich weiß ich
kann dieses social startup jetzt führen
ohne mir gedanken zu machen wie ich mein
studium finanzieren dass ich mir
gedanken machen muss wie ich meine
wohnung finanzieren weil meine mutter
mir gesagt hat ich investieren dich ich
investieren deiner zukunft auch wenn ich
dafür auf dem gewisse dinge verzichten
muss also sein argument ist ja
eigentlich seine mutter hat sich den
popo abgearbeitet damit tue es gut hass
oder vielleicht sogar besser hast als
dieses mal hatte und das wäre dann
ungerecht wenn man dir das geld
wegnehmen würde was war deine mutter
arbeit richtig es ist ungerecht weil ich
auf zeit verzichten mussten weil ich
immer darauf vorbereitet worden bin
was soziales zurückzugeben meine mutter
ist manchmal an arme länder gereist weil
ich kein geschwisterchen habe um mir zu
zeigen dass teilen wichtig ist dass es
wichtig ist etwas zurückzugeben meine
mutter hat auch jobs angenommen die gar
nicht oder wenig bezahlt war um eben das
auszugleichen dass sie gesagt hat ich
habe vielleicht meinen job der super gut
verdient und davon läge ich alles zurück
um halt eben auch soziale projekte zu
machen warum willst du ihr geld
wegnehmen das mag ja ganz möglich sein
dass es da einige charity ambitionen
gibt nur
kann man das ja nicht den reichen
überlassen dass sie entscheiden ob sie
vielleicht was abgeben oder nicht
sondern das ist einfach eine
demokratische frage und macht ist in
einer demokratie geteilt und die wird
auch nicht vererbt kapital bedeutet
vererbte macht dann und deshalb muss man
auch da besteuern und dass man sagt naja
deswegen war so wenig zeit da und die
mutter den polster aufgebaut viele leute
können sich gar kein polster aufbauen
weil die löhne so niedrig sind und sie
auch nicht gestiegen sind während das
kapital immer weiter steigt wir müssen
uns das eigentlich vorstellen wie bei
einem 100 meter lauf
die die geerbt haben die stehen
eigentlich schon am ziel und die anderen
versuchen das ziel zu erreichen und
schaffen das gar nicht mehr
deshalb müssen wir das erbe umverteilen
und deshalb ist es so wie es jetzt
gerade ist nicht gerecht wechsel
strukturelle und individuelle ist lage
also das modell von deiner mutter
löblich aber das kann nicht für alle so
gelten und wir wollen dass er nicht alle
so haben und bedeutet dass wir müssen
eine andere struktur schaffen es geht
darum barvermögen und es geht darum wenn
man eine immobilie erbt eine immobilie
wird auch versteuert bei
erbschaftssteuer wird immobilien und der
ganze besitzt mit eingerechnet dass das
vermögen genau das heißt wir haben mögen
das heißt meine mutter wenn sie damals
eine wohnung gekauft hat die in ddr der
brd zeiten viel viel weniger wert war
vom preis dass man sich damals noch
mieten und generell wohnungen käufe
leisten konnte und jetzt durch dieses
beton gold ist diese wohnung unglaublich
gewährt wenn ich allein schon über
diesen 400.000 euro betrag von dem dass
ich mich vielleicht gar nicht leisten
kann eine wohnung und eine immobilie
heißt nicht dass ich nie wieder zu ich
wollte gern mal wieder leders vorschlag
aufgreifen oder strukturelle gehen auf
die metaebene gern also wir haben
marlene gehört die sagt aus
strukturellen gründen auch aus aus
demokratischen gründen habe ich gehört
ist es sinnvoll dass wir eine höhere
erbschaftssteuer haben gesagt genau das
gegenteil warum denn marlene würde ich
sagen auch konkret auf ihrem beispiel
warum nimmt ziel nimmst du dann aber
nicht an und erhält diese investition
weil genau diese investition ist das was
das größte gemeinwohl erzeugt
erbschaften sollten
nicht umverteilt werden weil erben
vermögen in unternehmen gut angelegtes
gemeinnützig angelegt ist wenn menschen
geld in unternehmen investieren
entstehen dadurch arbeitsplätze und
entstehen dadurch die gründe für all
unsere steuern also all unsere bisherige
umfang handlung basiert darauf dass
menschen geld investieren und ein
strukturelles problem würde jetzt
bedeuten dass du das geld nimmst und auf
teils aber wo bleiben denn dann die
investitionen woher kommen dann die
arbeitsplätze von morgen der staat keine
arbeitsplätze vergibt er wolken vergibt
der stadt abend produktive arbeitsplätze
ist dass wir uns darauf einigen dass
jeder ausreden darf vielen dank erst du
darfst sagen ist der staat der bessere
unternehmer war seine frage wollt ihr
darauf antworten mitunter ist der staat
der bessere unternehmer aber es ist ja
keineswegs so dass immer nur dieses
kapital investiert wird wir haben die
unternehmenssteuer gesenkt in
deutschland und die investitionsquote
blieb niedrig da hat sich nichts getan
wir haben die erbschaftssteuer
reformiert dass alle firmen erben da
eigentlich sich austricksen können die
investitionsquote ist niedrig was
passiert das kapital vermehrt sich an
der börse und es vermehrt sich bei den
immobilien besonders und das ist ein
kapital das nicht neue arbeitsplätze
entstehen lässt dass er dafür sorgt dass
viele leute in prekären verhältnissen
leben und dafür aber dafür arbeiten
müssen dass erben sehr reich bleiben
seine entschuldigung seiner an die
investitionsquote braucht kann sich
nicht mehr wahnsinnig viel erhöhen weil
sie extrem hoch ist unsere vermögen die
in diesem land sind sind in erster
linien betriebsvermögen in anleihen und
ihn nicht selbst genutzten immobilien
vermögen und das ist natürlich genauso
auch betriebsvermögen über drei viertel
aller vermögen sind gemeinwohlorientiert
investiert bei arbeitsplätze daraus
entstehen weil steuern daraus entstehen
doch nicht und orient verteilt über die
hälfte dieser einkommen die daraus
wirtschaft sind wir jetzt schon
also woher soll denn der staat dann das
geld nehmen dass er jetzt umverteilt
wenn kein mensch mehr immobilien kaufen
kann und betriebe kaufen die sich
entscheiden bei probleme die alle etwas
angehen in einer demokratie ja ich finde
das gut deswegen wird da mein erbe
reingepasst
aber insgesamt muss man jedoch auch dass
du die ganze zeit von bedingungen
gesprochen werden es wird wird von
bedingungen gesprochen die ich für den
großteil der bevölkerung ist einfach
nicht ergeben
das kann einfach nicht sein dass wir in
deutschland so viele menschen haben sie
so hart arbeiten sich in prekären
verhältnissen wissen finden keine
aufstiegschancen haben und dann aber auf
der anderen seite menschen gibt die
nichts getan haben keine leistung
gebracht haben aber trotzdem um an
gelder bekommen und dass sich nicht
unter greifenden problem und da muss
dann vermögen neu gedacht werden
wir haben ein zutiefst strukturelles
problem die verhindert dass zu viele
menschen die dann eigentlich anders
versprechen dass die soziale
marktwirtschaft licher ordnung ergebnis
harter arbeit kannst du dir ein kleines
vermögen haid anschaffen und das ist ja
nicht erst seit ein zwei jahren das
problem das war schon immer das problem
in der bundesrepublik deutschland und
das besonders eklatant in den
marginalisierten communitys wenn man
sich die fünfzigerjahre anguckt die
sechzigerjahre anguckt also die ganz
viele menschen aus anderen ländern leben
gekommen mit dem versprechen und die
hoffnung darauf dass sie sich vielleicht
in eine bessere zukunft aufbauen können
heute ist das vermögen aber nicht auf
die marginalisierten kommen nun die sun
zu treffen und das ist eine riesengroße
ungerechtigkeit das kann man du nicht
sag ich dich festzuhalten orie du hast
es geschafft dass du einen schritt nach
vorne gegangen gestand ast asia warum
weil ich ihn zustimme dass es nicht
gerecht ist deutschland und nirgendwo
auf der welt ist derzeit gerecht die
frage ist bringt es was wenn wir private
privatpersonen besteuern brauchen wir
dafür wirklich diese erbschaftssteuer
und diese gelder die vielleicht einem
personen die halt über diesen 400.000
euro betrag ist müssen wir da wirklich
ansätzen in diesen mittelstand bei
nämlich superreicher das sind die leute
die meistens wert ins unternehmen
stecken die das geld haben eine stiftung
zu gründen um da zum beispiel das geld
zu lagern und damit keine steuern zu
müssen das heißt die leute umgeben das
ja das heißt da stimme ich euch
eindeutig zu dass wir wirklich dahin
gehen müssen und gucken müssen wer
umgeht diese steuer welche unternehmen
gleich das geld falsch oder versuchen zu
verstecken und steuerparadiese zuletzt
anders also erstmal respekt du hast es
geschafft das war heute so kleines
bisschen halb mutig nach vorne gegangen
sind
aber bleiben wir doch mal bei dem
mittelstands an wir müssen gleich ein
bisschen differenziert es gibt die
superreichen wo sich viel vermögen
konzentriert da habt ihr schon die
machtfrage gestellt es gibt aber auch
den mittelstand du bist selber
familienunternehmer die
berechtigt oder nicht berechtigt kann
wir diskutieren angst davor haben dass
zum beispiel der höhere erbschaftssteuer
dazu führt dass weniger investiert wird
das weniger tatsächlich unternommen wird
und tatsächlich vielleicht auch weniger
arbeitsplätze entstehen
das argument ist ja erst es nicht ganz
neu aber auch gar nicht so ein plausibel
wolfert oder da ist schon etwas dran
deswegen muss er auch eine
erbschaftssteuer bei unternehmen so
aussehen dass man nicht die situation
schafft dass die erben einfach sagen
dann muss ich alles verscherbeln und
dann ist alles weg sondern es gebe ja
die möglichkeit eine sehr hohe
erbschaftssteuer 1 zu führen aber die
wird dann gestundet abgezahlt so wie man
zum beispiel bafög abzahlen muss das
geschieht ja auch nicht im ersten
berufsjahr sondern über eine gewisse
zeit ich würde mal interessieren was
urlaub sei tui hat gesagt es gibt ein
strukturelles problem
ein offenbar wachsender teil der
bevölkerung kann es sich gar nicht mehr
leisten vermögen anzusparen
während tatsächlich dass er nun ein
faktum vermögen sich immer weiter
konzentriert überzeugt sich das würde
ich sagen dass wenn jemand 60 70 80
stunden arbeitet und sich nichts an
sparen kann oder investieren kann dann
kann man nicht mit geld umgehen da ist
ein ganz alter nehme ich kann dir selbst
hat sich auch das verlieren was auf die
zeit mit werden können struktur blind
ist
ich komme aus kleinunternehmen und
sorgen dafür dass leute so langsam
erlassen roland ganz ausleben
danach gehört somit 0 her ja ich habe
mir alles selbst aufgebaut und ich bin
während der schulzeit jeden tag arbeiten
kann ich bin nach der schulzeit arbeiten
und so weiter also wer sagt erarbeitet
und kann nicht geld sparen
dann hat er irgendein anderes problem
mit zoom eine höhere erbschaftsteuer
geht bin ich der meinung dass das sehr
viel osten nicht und hält gesprochen
wird und man lebt wir leben vor allem in
deutschland und österreich in einer
neidgesellschaft und da ist
einem lieber der nachbar hat auch nichts
weil ich nicht habe geschaut dass ich
sage ich freue mich für dich ich möchte
das auch anstreben bin ich danach will
und kann mir das selber aufbauen sagt
jeder der arbeiten wird und vermögen
aufbauen werden könnte das auch anhand
von mir aus sagen ich habe eine junge
gestartet also bei - und haben wir etwas
aufgebaut ich bin taxifahrer irgendwann
mal ein zeitungsbote ich bin ich war
kellner neben neben dem hauptberuf und
habe mir eben meinen lebensstandard
niedrig gehalten damit sich viel
einsparen kann kannst du kannst du
nachvollziehen dass es leute gibt die
genauso fleißig sind wie du und das
trotzdem nicht schaffen können weil sie
zum beispiel einen anderen background
haben
nein nicht weil sie in anderen branchen
sondern weil sie über ihre verhältnisse
leben na ja die frage ist einfach nicht
viel geld gibt ja eine chance für arbeit
habe ich das doch eigentlich nur 1000
euro verdiene dann arbeite ich dich doch
nicht dort und machen ihr aber wir
brauchen doch systemrelevante jobs das
hat sich doch gezeigt wir können ja
nicht alle nur noch mit bitcoins handeln
modellautos von dali er kann selbst
entscheiden was er arbeitet jetzt mal
unabhängig davon ich weiß ihr seid alle
nicht der meinung rulands dass jeder der
will auch viel vermögen ansparen kann
das wird wohl ein streitpunkt zwischen
euch bleiben
aber wenn wir darüber reden das ja ich
glaube die hälfte des vererbten
vermögens gar nicht aus arbeit und aus
lohnarbeit entstehen erstanden ist
sondern vermögen weitervererbt wird also
leistungslose vermögen
das widerspricht auch ihre argumentation
jedes vermögen musste irgendwann erspart
werden also jedes vermögen ist
irgendwann einmal nicht konsumierte ein
name gewesen also irgend jemand hat in
einer geschichte von generationen
irgendwann mal gesagt nein ich
konsumiere jetzt nicht ich lege es auf
die seite das geld so und derjenige hat
das getan weil er das in seiner familie
verantwortung übernehmen will
diese leistung hat bayer erbracht und
die leistung wollen wir hinterher dort
irgendwann nicht mehr nicht mehr gelten
lassen und diese leistung hat jemand
dann übernommen
und der konnte das aber auch nur
erhalten in dem es wieder investiert hat
meine vorfahren ganz sicher werden sie
sich nicht gedacht haben ach ich
verzichte jetzt damit ich das vermögen
irgendwie vermehren kann
das ist mehr die logik du als arbeiter
verzichtet jetzt damit ich mein vermögen
vermehren kann so funktioniert es aber
wir arbeiten arbeitsteilig in unserer
gesellschaft und das bedeutet es gibt
nicht so etwas wie ein vermögen das
einer sich aus gekapert hat sondern
haben alle anteil daran die mitarbeiter
das muss entsprechende und heilung ich
bin fertig in der primär verteilung sich
niederschlagen
und das ist nicht der fall jetzt haben
das pflaster steuergerechtigkeit dass
das problem der primär verteilung zwar
nicht löst aber wenigstens mal ein
bisserl eine ruhe reinbringen kann damit
wir uns ernsthaft darüber unterhalten
was hat arbeit und menschenwürde
eigentlich gemeinsam und wie können die
ein system aufbauen und weiter
bearbeiten mit den bestehenden
institutionen strukturen die
demokratischen öffentlichen strukturen
prozent auge darauf haben wir uns nicht
verlassen müssen das eben so macht was
vielleicht richtig ist bei der sich
einbildet er weiß das beste sondern wir
müssen uns anschauen was haben wir mal
wie kann man das nur darüber machen muss
fair sein in der verteilung und das
bedeutet momentan dass die strukturelle
ungleichheit ausgeglichen werden muss
dass alle wirklich behaupten können sie
hätten eine faire chance
das ist nicht der fall aber jetzt hat
gerd antworten und danach das marlene
warum nimmst du nicht ein erbe fürst das
unternehmen weiter und zahlst höhere
löhne
das unternehmen ist nicht mehr in
familienbesitz seit 97 deswegen gibt es
ja ein erbe und das andere ist wer bin
ich der könig oder was darf ich jetzt
entscheiden was sie macht es hagelt ist
der unternehmer du sterben also somit
zum einen ist das auch der absurde logik
zu sagen na ja dann gibt doch höhere
löhne allerdings davon aus dass dann
jeder der dann unternehmen geerbt hat
oder so dann auch bock drauf hat die
löhne zu erhöhen als gewerkschaft erlebe
ich auch gerade in deutschland
unglaublich viele unternehmen gehen
tarifflucht sie unterschlagen löhne wenn
wir die tennis die fleischerei brawn
scheint anschauen dass die ganz viele
menschen aus leiharbeitern benutzen um
dann alles zu drücken
dann denken wir so dann ist das ein sehr
nah gewann ein landesrat werner über
ansatz anhalt zu sagen na ja gut dann in
lockt ein erbe und bezahlt dann dein
mitarbeiterinnen dann einfach ein
bisschen mehr lohn ein das ist halt auch
angegangen werden wie würdest du
prozentual einschätzen wie viel wird
ausgebeutet und wie viel wird einfach
ordentlich bezahlt die große mehrheit
wird ganz klar ausgebaut
immer mehr staatseinnahmen in oslo bis
dahin versuchen wir versuchen nicht weil
es doch versuchen rosig bei mutmaßungen
zu bleiben sondern vielleicht bei den
großen linien pro land hat sich die
ganze zeit gemeldet ist ja genau
ungleich hat ja wenn das bei geld
anfängt dann könnte man ja auch sagen
bei behinderungen weil ein mensch ohne
beine hat er oft vielleicht weniger
vorteile also wo geht das dann hinein
schwarzer hinweis seiner mit einem
augenblick in der augen ausstechen weil
man sagen wie sie ungleich nein spaß und
sterbe ich bin schon ein wenig abend bin
habe ich die möglichkeit vor allem in
deutschland mehr zu arbeiten mehr zu
investieren und endvermögen daraus zu
machen aber ich hab's doch geschafft ich
bin schwarz und ich bin schwerbehindert
und ich hatte scheiß einstiegschancen
ich habe ich hatte fast gar keine
möglichkeiten nehmen weil er noch neben
der schule noch irgendwie lernen zu
können oder in wien noch mal neben job
machen zu können habe ich meine
behinderung zurückgehalten aber es gibt
wenig bis gar keine möglichkeiten genau
diese strukturelle benachteiligung
auszugleichen
wenn mir jetzt beispielsweise an diese
300 milliarden schätzungsweise dann halt
davon dass am meer abschöpfen würden
dann können wir auch an deutschen
punkten für gleichheit schaffen sodass
ein menschen aufsteigen können so ist
das halt nur leere versprechen wenn wir
jetzt bei den null haben haben wir die
gleiche chancen natürlich nicht allein
ist ja gar nicht so diskriminiert werde
aber das wäre jetzt wieder ein anderes
thema behinderte deswegen zusammen cola
das habe ein anderes thema für die
anderen beiden nicht die gleichen
chancen weil ich war einer privatschule
und ich kann jeder institution betreten
als würde sie mir gehören weil ich so
erzogen wurde also wir reden hier über
chancengerechtigkeit oder bessere
chancen gericht dafür will das noch mal
mit dieser chancengerechtigkeit zeigen
wo ist der unterschied wenn wir beide
geniale erfinder sind ich habe null euro
du hast eine million dann hast du den
unglaublichen vorteil dass du sofort ein
unternehmen aufbauen kannst ich muss
jemand suchen der mir kapital gibt und
ich werde vielleicht niemanden finden
weil ich keine beruhigung namen habe und
das ist nämlich genau der punkt und um
nochmal das konkrete beispiel
aufzugreifen wenn du erbschaftssteuer
zahlen muss dann hat der staat mehr geld
und kann dieses zum beispiel für
studenten aus prekären verhältnissen
ausgeben und damit profitieren die die
weniger haben davon dass
erbschaftssteuer dass rainer wendt du
kannst nicht entscheiden wo das geld
hingeht glaubst du wer da mit der
demokratie demokratische entscheidung es
geht uns alle etwas an bedürfnis rein
basteln in den start wir können mit
entscheiden was wir bei dem unternehmen
nicht können wir können nicht mit
entscheiden wie die das machen wir
müssen uns diesem wohlwollen ausliefern
genau das gleiche gilt für philanthropie
wenn wir geld sich morgen überlegt
waffen sind roku ja dann macht das der
punkt ist beim start haben die
demokratische beteiligungsmöglichkeit da
sehen wir jedes mal wenn er nicht eine
transall ist und weil die öffentliche
hand haben die drauf guckt und da können
wir mitmischen wie es verteilt sondern
wäre ein basteln in die entscheidungen
was wichtig ist weil wir alle gemeinsam
entscheiden was wichtig ist und das
können bin nicht wenn es einzig menschen
gibt den einst positionen einzel macht
ausüben eine art und weise die an den
vorteil ist ischen system dran ist und
das ist was wir haben dem muss
widersprochen werden wir haben wir sind
eine marktwirtschaft in einer
marktwirtschaft kann eigentum nur dann
erhalten werden wenn es gemeinwohl
produktiv ist nur dann wenn ich es
investiere so dass hintenraus produkte
entstehen die irgend jemand haben will
und die auch irgendjemanden kauft kauft
ich glaub ich mein eigentum wenn ich
produkte produziere die keiner kaufen
will warum kauft jemand diese produkte
offensichtlich es gibt nichts
demokratisches den markt der markt
entscheidet frei darüber was er haben
will und was er nicht will und da bleibt
hinten heraus dass eigentum erhalten
dass bedürfnisse befriedigt nutzen
schafft katar sieger mit der leistung
aus der unternehmer hängt ausschließlich
am wohlwollen des marktes ab das heißt
er ist der schwächste in der
machtposition auch jetzt hast du am ende
gehört noch mal schön alle nach hinten
getreten
wir sind tatsächlich aber jetzt trotzdem
in der phase das ziel dieser sendung ist
ein kompromiss zu finden und ich weiß
hier sind gemüter aufeinander geprallt
ist wurde auch hitzig vollkommen klar
trotzdem bitte ich euch geht mal in euch
und versucht darüber nachzudenken wie
schaffe ich es vielleicht auch über
meinen eigenen schatten zu springen und
vielleicht ein schritt auf die anderen
zuzugehen was müssten die vorschlagen
was könntet ihr vorschlagen also wir
sind jetzt in einer art kompromiss runde
angekommen vielleicht kommen wir noch
ein bisschen näher zusammen
mein vorschlag ist jetzt das bisherige
system mit großzügigen freibeträgen und
dem schutz für familienunternehmen
bleibt erhalten vielleicht bauen wir
sogar drei beträge aus so dass am ende
kein unternehmen irgendwie gefahr läuft
seinen arbeitsplatz oder eine
innovationskraft zu verlieren das geld
aber was dann kommen wir zu den
superreichen vielleicht das was dann
noch weit darüber liegt wird höher
besteuert das heißt wir erheben erheben
den erbschaftssteuer satz an
und weiter aber die freibeträge
vielleicht sogar noch weiter aus wenn
ihr sagt ja es ist zumindest mal ein
anfang dann würde ich euch bitten kommt
einen schritt nach vorne so wie es einst
asia gerade tut und wenn ihr das nicht
sagt dann bleibt ja verstehen
ihr bleibt alles stehen generation set
ist entscheidend offen dafür vorschläge
warum war wäre ja das nichts für dich
erbschaftssteuer seitz erhöhen
freibeträge auch also ich finde die
freibeträge sind ja so wird die gerade
halt sind aber da bin ich hatte
natürlich dass sie hoch genug sind als
dass ich da jetzt irgendwie sagten
unterstützung zu
ferner hat eben nicht verlaufen jetzt
seid ihr dran also merkt euch bitte wo
er steht und dann steckt ihr bitte mal
die köpfe zusammen und versucht
irgendwie die gegenseite das vorkommen
wenn das klappt
das entspreche mit gleichen ausland also
100 millionen ist mir nicht reich also
ich die jungs und natürlich so jetzt
wird hier rechts und links noch fleißig
diskutiert was für eine folge oder ja
was wäre der neue vorschlag wie könnten
diese beiden gruppen mit welchem
kompromissvorschlag näher zusammenkommen
ob das heute noch klappt unter diese
bieten
ich schlage vor gruppe grün fängt an was
ist euer kompromissvorschlag also dieses
thema chancengerechtigkeit ist fraglos
die wichtigste gerechtigkeit in einer
freiheitlichen gesellschaft und dafür
muss der staat geld in die hand nehmen
und wenn er dafür mehr geld investieren
müssen dann bitte nicht von der substanz
sondern vom mehrwert und mehrwerte
gewinn oder das einkommen also wenn dann
müssen wir über höhere gewinnbesteuerung
wo wir schon ganz oben sind und höhere
einkommensbesteuerung wo man auch schon
relativ weit oben sind aber wenn dann
müssen über das nachdenken nicht über
die besteuerung der substanz
ausgerechnet gerd schlägt vor höhere
gewinne und einkommensteuer
niemand steht ja er damit noch den
unternehmern die anfangen die kein geld
im rücken haben im wege also die
besteuert man jetzt plötzlich stärker wo
man ja vielleicht wirklich noch sagen
kann da wird was geleistet
und warum soll man nicht gerade da das
geld nehmen was einfach nur ein wenn den
schoß fällt
ok also ihr geht nicht nach vorne alle
drei nicht habe ich richtig verstanden
okay also bis jetzt noch nicht ganz so
viele nach vorgekommen aber jetzt habt
ihr den vorschlag vielleicht schafft ihr
seid unser vorschlag ist dass wir bei
den 400.000 freibetrag bleiben für
privatleute die dann erben übrigens dann
auch nicht mehr an familie gebunden denn
wir leben nicht mehr in dynastischen
zeiten
wir sagen aber dann dass das erbe
darüber hinaus so versteuert werden muss
wie das einkommen und genau so
progressiv und wir sagen auch niemand
muss mehr als eine million euro erben
niemand braucht mehr geld und bei den
firmen wird es so sein dass die das
stunden können dass sie es nicht auf
einmal bezahlen müssen und dass es aber
auch die bedingungen gibt dass diese
firmen sich an die tarif erhalten
das sich auch mit den gewerkschaften
abstimmen und diese steuer wird
zweckgebunden sein für bildung und klima
zweckgebundene steuer das ist kein das
ist kein kompromiss vorschlag das ist
die vernichtung des familienunternehmens
zu verstehen ich versuche erst mal zu
verstehen das heißt niemand muss mehr
als eine million euro haben das heißt ab
einer million euro 100 prozent
erbschaftssteuer genau es gab in den
70er jahren mal einen
präsidentschaftskandidaten den usa
der wollte genau das sein führen sogar
schon ab 500.000 wir sind also sehr
großzügig heute aber aber dafür zumal
erbschaft ist nur eine von vielen
vermögenssteuern sind die wir als
gesamtpaket brauchen um dafür zu sorgen
dass wir strukturelle gleichstellung
haben damit wir überhaupt das davon
sprechen können dass wir
marktwirtschaftlich arbeiten weil wenn
wir nicht am gleichen stockerl anfange
nennt man auch nicht am gleichen wir
können also recht wenig kurze frage ich
wollte nur mich erkundigen die sinne 1
millionen sind da gegenstände dabei oder
geht es nur sparvermögen das ganze
vermögen okay also auch einiges im
maschinenring erbe der halt weil sie
nicht viel wert ist weil er gold mit
diamanten besetzt ja dann ist er schon
drin oder einen picasso oder muss ich
sein dass ihre kinder sonstige aus
persönlichkeiten die eine total
verstaatlichung alles unternehmertums
bedeutet dass ab dem kollektivismus im
max ist ein modell das
unternehmensvermögen nein bei den fall
bohrung ist es ja anders bei den
vermögen wollen wir eine hohe
erbschaftssteuer haben eine höhere als
jetzt auch für die familienunternehmen
aber die können das durch ihre profite
nach und nach ab zahlen aber da soll
natürlich jetzt nicht abrasiert werden
sondern die haben die möglichkeit dann
über ihre profite eine ordentliche
erbschaftssteuer zu zahlen und das
können wir schaffen denn ich glaube an
unsere deutschen familienunternehmen
zumal es gibt auch stille beteiligungen
stundungen kredite alles was einem
normalen menschen zumutbar ist ist auch
einem unternehmer zumutbar
das heißt ich diese grenze gilt auch für
unternehmen die eine million grenze und
ab da muss ich dahinter vermögen und
schulden abzubauen
ok
gut der vorstand versucht hinten den
ausweg zu finden
was bin ich in den kopf rein gehen
werden das so in den kapitalistischen
system leistung soll belohnt werden
ungefähr
es gibt das studio ungefähr 300
milliarden uns da gehen 300 milliarden
an einnahmen die wir für die
gesellschaft für das gebäude und müssten
nicht alle 300 milliarden euro können
noch deutlich mehr als sieben acht oder
zehn wir ja noch einnehmen und dann für
das gemeinwohl zu machen und diesen
widerstand der vor allem von
privilegierten menschen halt kommt das
verstehe ich hatte einfach nicht ich
nicht das ist nicht der widerstand gegen
das gemeinwohl gegen die menschen sind
ich glaube dass dieses geld bei den
unternehmens gemeinwohl nützlicher
angelegt ist weil die nämlich
arbeitsplätze mit schaffen weil die
nämlich gewinne machen wo dann wieder
steuern daraus erwirtschaften
doch nicht nur große soziale
ungleichheit gerade sie sammelten sie
sind größer als das ein großes problem
aber dafür wieder einen punkt wo wir uns
auf einigen wir uns nicht einigen kann
man kann sich ja verschiedenste modelle
die es gibt anschauen und
gemeinschaftlich diskutieren ich würde
es nicht vorgeben wollen aber es gibt
zum beispiel tom petty der sagt 5
prozent des staatshaushalts lassen sich
aus vermögenssteuern blockieren und kann
man dann um verteilen so dass jeder
mensch zum 25 geburtstag ein erbe
bekommt von 120 oder 125000 es ist eine
möglichkeit von vielen umzuverteilen und
wir müssen sie uns alle anschauen und
gut aus kaarst von wie man es macht aber
gemeinsam demokratisch und nichtig
dieses vorgehen das würde ich zum
beispiel da will ich ergänzen ich finde
zum beispiel dass das unmöglich
gleichberechtigung zu schaffen
finde ich ich darf das bekommen was
meine mutter verdient hat verzichtet
dafür aber auf dieses erbe vom staat
und dafür bekommt eine andere person aus
finanzschwächeren haushalten die ganz
viele chancen ich hatte die ich hatte
kommt dann vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
dass wenn ich schön bei damit werde eine
gerechtigkeit
dazu braucht man daten werden viel hat
die wir auch nicht haben das vielleicht
so ist es transparenz von der politik
transparenz zu unternehmen transparenz
wie viel zahlen sie eine
also transparent transparenz transparenz
demokratie und transparenz
steuergerechtigkeit jetzt wir sind uns
einig war auch naja da stelle ich den
moment
das ist jetzt also eine folge gewesen wo
ich wenn ich der kompromiss onkel sein
will relativ gescheitert bin
so oder so hilft es euch vielleicht
trotzdem euch eine eigene meinung zu
bilden denn ich glaube die argumente und
das ist ja ein großer teil dieser
sendung sind hoffentlich klar geworden
dankeschön
[Applaus]
wie auch immer man zu diesem thema steht
im kampf gegen die soziale ungleichheit
erscheint die erbschaftssteuer ein
geeigneteres mittel zu sein als zb die
vermögenssteuer die viel bürokratischer
und komplexer daherkommt so oder so
müssen wir von allen parteien in diesen
bundestagswahlkampf erwarten können dass
sie sich glasklar positionieren wie
wollen sie die steuer erhöhen und wenn
sie gar nicht erhöhen wollen dann müssen
sie wenigstens sagen warum nicht auch
ihr solltet natürlich eine position
finden und wenn euch 13 fragen gefällt
dann könnt ihr hier unseren kanal
abonnieren
hier findet ihr eine weitere folge 13
fragen und hier gibt es ein weiteres
video zum thema